[Music]
hello and welcome to I'd like to know
this is our Bible and answer program
here at Secrets unsealed and some TV and
it is as we always say one of our
favorite programs so thank you you so
very much for spending just a little of
your no doubt busy day with us and for
taking the time to send in your
questions and to be part of this Bible
Understanding experience to my left is
Pastor David Salazar and and we're we're
having a little fun with that because I
I had a senior moment a little while ago
and and forgot somebody who I knew very
very well so Pastor who who who
superintends our Latino work here at
sutv doing a very very fine job Pastor
good to have you here thank you Pastor
CA it's always an honor a privilege to
learn from you from Pastor Bo of course
and to share this space and time with
you guys thank you by the way I'm step
bore I was going to say if I slip up on
this thing I'm gonna be in deep trouble
this is Pastor Steven bore he's a
president and founder of this very fine
Ministry and is always a joy to study
with him because he is a student of the
word taught for many years uh fluent in
both languages in fact both you guys
speak both languages I speak 1.5
languages but pastor always good to have
you here thank you CA it's always good
to work with you on this program and of
course this program wouldn't be this
program without you so we want to thank
you in advance for what you do to make
this program possible should you like to
get in on the fun and we do have fun
here at secret unsealed and some TV let
me say this the rumors are true we do
love and care about each other here at
Secrets unsealed and that goes
throughout this whole Ministry uh we
have fun in the Lord and uh you're part
of that when you send in your questions
to TV ATS tv.org that again is TV at
susum as in Mary
tv.org send in your Bible related
questions and we promise you we will get
an answer to them if indeed an answer
can be found we'll find it and we'll
bring it to you again if you don't hear
your question answered right away be
patient with us please have a little Gra
a little Mercy because the stack is
rather impressive and that's a good
problem to have better to have more
questions than few questions we have
questions coming in from around the
world which we like because it lets us
know where we are touching lives and
changing Destinies and it it gives us an
idea of our footprint so when you send
in your questions please just put a
little note where the question is coming
from it doesn't have to be the exact
street or the Zach Andress give us the
country that'll work fine and we thank
you in advance for what you are going to
do Pastor Salazar if you would have
prayer for us then we'll launch out into
today's program absolutely let us pray
Heavenly Father we thank you once again
for allowing us to come to your throne
of grace and to seek from your presence
the blessing of the Holy Spirit to be
able to remember and to share from your
word the truth that is found in it and
we pray that you will help us to answer
questions that may really Point people
closer to you bring them closer to the
knowledge of your word and we pray that
you will allow us to have words and the
answers that really May uh present
clearly the evidence found in your
scriptures in Jesus name amen amen amen
Pastor B I'm going to lay hands on you
suddenly and ask you to read this
question that comes to us from Jane it
is really a a housekeeping issue from a
former program and um I'll put it in
your hands and you can sort of work your
way through
that all right basically basically this
question is based on an answer that we
provided for a question on a previous
program uh Pastor Salasar and I were on
the program and the question was
regarding uh the actually it's a comment
more than a question regarding the
serpent that was raised in the
wilderness by Moses MH um Pastor Salasar
and I both mentioned that uh Moses uh
commanded this uh serpent uh to be um
melted in the fire because the people
had become idolatrous they were
worshiping this Serpent and so uh
basically um it's not technically true
that Moses was the one who commanded it
to be uh you know uh melted but uh
actually it was Hezekiah much later on
maybe 7 or 800 years later uh and so um
you know in all fairness to the person
who wrote to us we want to make sure
that we're 100% ACC um you know we are
fallible human beings we do make
mistakes and um you know when we get to
heaven we'll all be mistake free amen uh
but we one thing I do appreciate is that
people are checking out what we're
saying amen and when they find something
that is not perhaps exactly accurate
we're not talking about major things
we're talking about minor things uh then
um you know let us know and call us out
so that we can make the correction on
the program so that everybody can be
aware of what the Bible specifically
teaches however uh my final comment
before you guys can measure in uh is
that the principle that we expressed is
very much valid uh because uh the people
had begun to worship this um this
serpent right and uh you know it wasn't
something that happened overnight I'm
sure that it was a process they had been
doing it for some time
so even though we got the U specific
time when it was melted wrong uh the
principle is that it was melted and the
reason was valid they were worshiping it
amen amen I think just just to add to
what you're were saying pastor Bor you
know the the influence um of the
idolatry was something that the the Lord
of course wanted to prevent the children
of Israel from from pursuing from
following as nations of of surrounding
them and so um we don't really have uh
any indication when exactly it started
when they actually went into seeing this
serpent as something that they can burn
incense to uh what we know for sure as
you know we were uh you know point out
and and I'm thankful for that correction
is that it was made by King hezekia much
later and it was uh evidence and the
Lord saw that as a as a good thing that
he destroy that because they had misused
what it was supposed to be a symbol of
and so I think that your point as as you
mentioned clearly you know idolatry is
something that the Lord did not want to
to to pursue they did not want their
children to ever connect in their
worship experiences even and so we have
to uh remember remind people that you
know the Lord does not see any type of
adultery of any form no matter how
closely could be a symbol of God or the
godhead uh any of that is really uh you
know going against the Lord himself and
going against his word so just uh verify
that and clarify that you know you know
the one thing I would add that is that
when we look at the process of idolatry
the the syncretism it tends not to be a
sharp left turn it tends to infuse its
way into the church seep its way into
the church and people tend to go off the
rail slowly it's like uh you know rarely
do you have a a blowout for the most
part it's usually a slow leak you know
the tires going down slowly you come out
one morning it's flat well um and I say
that because uh Jane and and we do thank
you Jane for for your your your input uh
she gives us a timeline from the time
that the uh Brazen serpent was erected
till the time it was
destroyed my thinking is and and the
textual evidence would suggest that you
can't give a hard time from A to B or
from beginning to end um
the text simply says that by the time
Hezekiah came along this practice had
been followed for a while but it doesn't
tell you how long or when it began right
um the Bible gives no indication that
there was any problem with this the
serpent in the wilderness this came in a
little bit later by a series of of of
really bad kings who didn't correct
anything and Hezekiah stood in the Gap
to correct things so when he began his
correction this thing had been going on
for a while I doubt seriously had that
the Lord would allow this thing to go on
for 700 years before he redressed it so
um we we don't have a a a time for its
beginning but we do know that Hezekiah
ended it and and he did a number of
things he fixed the door to the temple
opened the temple up cleaned it up did a
number of things he was a good King so
uh thank you Jane uh for what you uh
have done and for your study as you
mentioned before those in Brio more
noble and those in thessalonica because
they checked it out for themselves and
so we have no problem with with that we
we thank you I mention just one one
further thing MH and that is that to use
the serpent in the wilderness that
people were to behold in order to be
healed as a justification to have idols
and bow before them is a tremendous
stretchh because that's exactly what
Israel did yeah they they they were
worshiping The Serpent and so God said
destroy that serpent that was made so
there was no justification for them uh
bowing in worshiping the serpent right
in the wilderness God didn't say oh Bow
Down worship the service serpent pray to
the serpent no and you were mentioning
that uh before as we were talking uh
furthermore we're dealing here with
typology yes before Jesus Christ came to
this earth right there were all kinds of
types that represented Christ a rock
does that mean that we bow before a rock
no a a Shepherd does that mean we bow
before a Shepherd uh bread does does
that mean that we bow before bread uh
you know there's all kinds of symbols in
the Old Testament where where God tried
to teach the different functions of
Jesus when he came to this earth and to
use that as a justification for Bowing
down and worshiping to Idols today in
church is just totally beyond the beyond
the realm yeah you you've you've opened
up uh another little Avenue there God
said look and live so that lets know let
it let them know that their healing was
outside of themselves and that was a
point that that God was trying to make
that it's outside of you um nowhere do
we get a a call to worship that serpent
offer incense to that serpent the
problem is the reason that commandment
is there is because man has this
predilection to worship objects instead
of the God who created those objects we
tend to take these visual shortcuts
because they're venient but it it takes
away it diminishes who and what God is
and what he's doing so that commandment
is there for a specific reason because
God knew that we have this this bent
towards worshiping things instead of God
yeah and the Commandment clearly forbids
two things it
forbids making a Graven image and
secondly bowing before the Graven image
yeah and so uh there's no evidence that
this serpent was to be worshiped no no
connection with worship am amen well
done well done Jane again we thank you
um for your your Insight and for your
studying and we we appreciate that
amen now is our next one is the next one
Adrian Adrian Adrian or is it adri yeah
Adrian okay
um this one is directed to pastor bour
and we have all sat at your feet as
you've given us uh a really fine
presentation uh on the 24 Elders so I'm
going to loose you and let you go
because the question is is is is
specifically put to you and this is
something that you spent a lot of time
on and actually when I began looking at
this and listening to you you you
actually move the needle for me on this
understanding so I'm going to I'm going
to read the question and then I'm going
to take the chains off you and let you
let you go at it all
right um I very much enjoy your
presentations and I've learned a great
deal in your presentation of the 24
Elders I was concerned about the KJV
King James version being described as a
wrong or bad translation and started to
think about how it could be explained as
to who exactly is redeemed in quotes so
it makes sense in preserving the
Integrity of the translated word um
dispute about the correctness of the
translation might have might have a
detrimental effect on people hearing
that explanation who may not have much
knowledge of the Bible this is why I
want to kind of let you walk through
this because you're not trying to
destroy credibility of the scriptures
you're just trying to say that there are
little errors in certain translations
that need to be accounted for so let me
stop talking let you let you get at it
okay well first of all we need to
understand that we don't have any
autographs when it comes to the Bible
autograph means we don't have the
originals that were written by the by
the writers I I was going to say authors
but God is the author of The Writers um
the fact is that all we have uh
particularly of the New Testament is
copies of copies of copies and you know
in the process of copying sometimes
there are errors in
transmission the problem becomes more
complex when you realize that um there
are not only multiple
manuscripts but you also have many
different translations from those
manuscripts and some people say well you
know uh how can you trust the Bible you
know Pastor Bo I by the way I never said
that the King James is bad I I've always
said that the King James is a good
translation I like it it's poetic it's
reverent it was made not for commercial
purposes but to spread the word of God
not like today they print Bibles because
they want to S Bibles it's a very good
translation however we need to read a
statement from white this is volume one
of selected messages page 16 MH where
Ellen White wrote some look to us
Gravely that means seriously and say
don't you think that there might have
been some mistake in the copyist or in
the translators
mhm and she answers this is all probable
no she doesn't say possible she says all
this is probable and the mind that is so
narrow that it will hesitate uh and
stumble over this possibility or
probability would be just as ready to
stumble over the mysteries of the
inspired word because their feeble Minds
cannot see through the purposes of God
yes they would just as easily stumble
over the plain facts that the common
mind will accept and discern the Divine
and to which God's utterance is plain
and beautiful full of marrow and fatness
all the
mistakes and by the way the context
indic indicates all the mistakes in
copying and translation will not cause
trouble to One Soul or cause any feet to
stumble that would not manufacture
difficulties from the plainest revealed
truths uh so we need to recognize that
translations uh reflect the biases
sometimes of the translators however
that's not a problem because you can go
to other places in Scripture that
clarify that that issue in the
translation mhm now um I did a series of
six 1-hour presentations on the 24
Elders I used to believe like you did
that the 24 Elders were those who
resurrected with Jesus and went to
heaven but you know and that's what I
taught when I taught theology in South
America but since then I don't accept
any concept or interpretation of script
RT without checking it out for myself MH
amen and so I sat down and I studied the
issue of the 24 elders and there is no
doubt whatsoever by all of the evidence
and by the way uh you can access the
series on the 24 Elders uh online and on
our app I would encourage everybody to
You Know download our app uh you can
watch all six presentations make sure
you watch them in order I have one
entire presentation on this issue of the
translation because uh basically uh the
more modern version is the only version
that seems to indicate that the 24
Elders were redeemed from the Earth is
the King James version MH all other
versions without exception say that the
elders are singing about the Redeemed
they are not the
redeemed and uh you know this is
resolved either by stating that the
manuscripts that are used by the more
modern versions are the correct
manuscripts the correct reading or
there's another way of resolving it and
that is that um Ellen White states that
the
Angels uh actually join the redeemed in
singing the song of the redeemed mhm so
both the
elders and the Angels Sing the song of
the redeem so let's suppose that the
elders are human beings let's just
suppose for for a minute right or that
the that they're Angels like the modern
uh uh State well listen to this
quotation from 7 BC
9:22 Holy Angels will join in the song
of the redeemed
mhm so if the elders are Angelic they're
still joining the redeemed and singing
she continues though they cannot sing
from experimental knowledge because they
haven't experienced
Redemption uh he hath washed Us in his
own blood and redeemed us unto God those
are words that they sing yet they
understand the great Peril from which
the people of God have been saved were
they not sent to lift up for them a
standard against against the enemy they
can fully sympathize with the glowing
Ecstasy of those who have overcome by
the blood of the lamb and the word of
their testimony uh so so I believe that
the 24 Elders are angels the highest
angels I don't why identif I that
represents the world that never sins in
other words they're the representatives
of uh the different worlds in the
Heavenly Council and you know we don't
have time in this program to go through
all of the evidence because it it
already is there uh for you to access
online uh but I need to make it clear
that I did not say that the King James
version is bad I simply said that
there's a better a better translation of
Revelation 5: 9 and 10 uh so uh the King
James is a very good version um by the
way the NIV is much better on the state
of the Dead uh than than the King James
you know you read for example Acts
chapter 2 uh when Peter is preaching uh
he quotes psalm 16 you will not leave my
soul in
Hell Jesus is saying you will not leave
my soul in hell that creates all kinds
of problems for us it does because it
gives the impression that the soul of
Jesus went to hell the NIV says you will
not leave me in the grave mhm much
better much better translation you know
even the King James Ellen White states
that in Daniel uh chapter 8 where it
says uh he took away the daily the
little horn took away the daily in many
versions the word sacrifice is there
Ellen White says it doesn't belong there
so there are places in the King James
version where there needs to be some
adjustments doesn't mean it's a bad
translation it simply means that we need
to study to make sure that it's the best
translation you know a couple things
occur to me because that it was that
understanding I was I did all most of my
Bible memorization in King James Bible
you know everything that's just and you
get that in your head well I I went
redeemed from the earth well that was
that was period full stop for me right
they had to come from the earth um it
wasn't until I I heard your explanation
uh that uh like I said the needle moved
for me um
the Bible is the early fathers in the
our church determined that as far as
your faith and practice is concern it is
it is inherent as as how you ought to
think about God and how you ought to
live for God no mistakes I don't think
anybody's going to miss out on the
Kingdom on the 24 Elders at least I hope
they don't of course uh on that so it's
it's not a salivic issue we're not going
to kick you out of the church if you
have a different view on the 24 Elders
um so as far as faith and practice is
concerned it's it's solid you can trust
it you can take it as it were to the
bank are there some little you know
first John uh 1:7 uh there are three
bear witness in heaven that's in King
James and no place else you know all
kinds of things you find but no one's
going to miss the kingdom because of
that so as far as how you ought to think
about God how you ought to relate to God
and your fellow man no problem with with
with the Bible maybe I can mention one
further thing uh sometimes the King
James version
is a better version than the other ones
than the modern ones for example in
Revelation 11 it says time will be no
longer in the King James version that
links uh Revelation 11 with Daniel 8:14
yes the end of the prophetic periods but
most modern versions translate there
will no longer be any
delay and when you look at the word
coronos that is used there for time you
look at the use of the word in
Revelation in the rest of the new
Testament that is not a good translation
mhm so there are times when the King
James is much more accurate M than the
modern versions so uh what I'm saying is
that we need to compare all of the
versions and we need to go to the
software and look at what the Greek has
to say and what the Hebrew has to say
there's not a lot of controversy about
the Hebrew because that's based on the
masic text right which is quite accurate
they were very careful in copying but
because there are so many manuscripts of
the New Testament
and there are small differences then you
know you have to do a lot more research
U one prime example Revelation
22:14 blessed are those who wash their
robes most modern versions say the King
James says blessed are those who keep
his Commandments uh so which is the best
translation well they're both true
because Revelation uses wash their robes
and you just keep the Commandments
elsewhere where there's no controversy
and so let's not let's not drown in a
glass of water let's just do our
research and discover what is the best
translation based on comparing one text
with another yeah yeah well said yes
yeah it's it's important that we you
know we encourage people to read the
Bible read whatever version they may
have uh as you mentioned probably the
King James is the most um liked in the
English world uh probably has to me most
most accurate in many ways but that
doesn't mean that he not you know has
certain mistakes of translation that we
have to be aware of and that's why we
have the scripture to compare scripture
to scripture and find the truth yeah
amen um the computer is a wonderful
thing particularly when you're studying
the word of God Amen those kinds of
things that would take us hours and days
you can do with a touch of a button you
know you can become a student of the
word and we pray that you are students
of the word we'll see you again next
time here on I'd like to know bye-bye
and God bless
[Music]